vi siete mai chiesti cosa sta dentro una
tazza di tè
sostanzialmente acqua acqua nella quale
viene dissolto vengono disciolte delle
foglie essiccate in modo diversificato
per fare dei forti dei the leggeri de
the di colore diverso
ma sostanzialmente e acqua acqua che
diventa un infuso e quindi una bevanda
nobile altezzosa talvolta ma anche una
bevanda utilizzata per momenti di
convivialità per momenti di socialità
per dare il benvenuto per dare un
arrivederci
molto spesso in molti paesi del mondo
il tè è una bevanda identitaria delle
comunità locali
iban
rappresentano una comunità indigena che
vive in un posto lontanissimo da qui
nella malesia e precisamente nel borneo
della malesia
è una comunità che vive all'interno
della foresta pluviale un luogo
difficile in cui vivere
per chi non è abituato per chi non c'è
nato è una comunità che è abituata a
vivere è stata abituata a vivere da
nomade fino a un centinaio di anni fa
adesso è stanziale viva all'interno di
strutture abitative che prendono il nome
di long house sono delle case di legno
in cui all'interno si trovano tante
piccole unità abitative per le famiglie
della comunità
legate insieme da un lungo corridoio che
il corridoio della socialità il
corridoio della convivialità il
corridoio del del momento in cui si
condivide ciò che è avvenuto nella
giornata momento in cui il corridoio in
cui si condivide il tè
e iban sono agricoltori
sono stati a lungo nomadi nelle foreste
ed erano tanti anni fa anche dei
tagliatori di teste
avevano questo seguivano questo rituale
legato ad una sorta di sacralità che
oggi fortunatamente non seguono più
per quanto conservino ancora delle teste
quasi con un ruolo scaramantico
all'interno delle long house
difficilmente riconoscibili per la
verità
vivono di agricoltura vivono di ciò che
coltivano consumano ciò che coltivano
prevalentemente riso
ma sono anche a bellissimi coltivatori
di pepe
io mi ritrovavo lì proprio perché loro
coltivano il pepe del presidio slow food
del pepe di rhemes del presidio slow
food
una coltivazione che nasce per
contrastare il dilagare della
deforestazione
della foresta pluviale e il
la diffusione del sempre più spinta
della palma da olio questa comunità
impegnata a coltivare il pepe lo fa con
con straordinaria capacità del pepe
conoscono tutto conoscono come si pianta
come si coltiva fanno questi allevamenti
su strutture permanenti che durano
moltissimi anni sono davvero abili anche
nelle situazione per cui vivo dei
momenti di grande condivisione in questi
campi che mi affascinano moltissimo
visto che prima la prima volta che mi
ritrovo con questa comunità
noto però che concimano
concimano in una maniera
davvero
inaspettata inspiegabile e mi raccontano
che il concime io lo fornisce
gratuitamente il governo quindi hanno un
concime un prodotto chimico di sintesi
ricevuto gratis dal governo e lo
distribuiscono con una diciamo
puntualità quasi davvero inspiegabile
perché non c'è bisogno
eppure io soffro vedere questa questa
distribuzione di concime chimico di
sintesi
realizzata in questo modo perché i
terreni sono in pendenza
perché queste pendenze finiscono sui
fiumi e fiumi non sono un luogo di non
sono rappresentano semplicemente una una
risorsa dell'ecosistema di per sé
rappresentano una risorsa di sussistenza
per le comunità che vivono nella foresta
pluviale ma intervenire con questi
argomenti
così un po a gamba tesa all'interno di
una comunità indigena
io che vengo da lontano un po complesso
perché
rifiuto l'idea di avere l'approccio di
colui che viene da lontano e vuole
insegnare qualcosa e così diciamo soffro
in parte di questa di questa esperienza
perché da un lato vedo un un ecosistema
straordinario vedo un posto ricco di
biodiversità biodiversità animale
flora spontanea veramente
straordinaria anche per la relazione che
ha saputo instaurare con la comunità
soffre una sofferenza perché da un altro
lato quella tecnologia invece porta
chimica di sintesi che non può fare
altro che portare alla devastazione alla
desertificazione che noi viviamo già da
tanti anni nei nostri ambienti nel mondo
occidentale a causa di un modello
agricolo industriale che ha devastato
buona parte della nostra del nostro
mondo agricolo
arriva il giorno della partenza è un
momento di gioia un momento di
convivialità e un momento in cui ci si
riunisce tutti insieme all'interno della
longa house per scambiarsi esperienze
per scambiarsi
racconti
io racconto della mia vita della mia
vita di agronomo del racconto delle mie
esperienze con slow food e in giro per
il mondo racconto della mia famiglia
perché so che raccontare le storie della
mia famiglia rappresenta un modo per
unire il legame con con questi con
questa comunità ed è il momento in cui
il capo del villaggio
si impegna a preparare il tè perché il
tempo è la bevanda della convivialità e
la bevanda del commiato la bevanda del
saluto e un modo per abbracciare
l'ospite e c'è questa preparazione del
tè molto tradizionale in cui il capo del
villaggio cominciò di comincia a versare
il tè da una teiera all'altra da una
teiera all'altra proprio in attesa di
raggiungere la giusta di missione
la giusta concentrazione dell'infuso il
tè una bevanda identitaria e quindi a
lui tocca a lui spetta prepararla per
l'ospite il capo del villaggio versa te
in una tazza trasparente e fumante nella
porge
io rifiuto il tema
non è un semplice astenersi dal bere
quella tazza di tè ios costo con la
tazza di tè verso il capo del villaggio
devo dirgli che un primo momento ho
pensato al fatto che loro in passato
fossero dei tagliatori di teste quindi
ho detto sarah che che la mia testa
rimane qui ma
faccio un azione che crea il silenzio
tombale
nella comunità
arrivano 30 secondi di silenzio che
durano un'eternità vero che il tempo ha
sempre la stessa durata però sappiamo
bene che a seconda della tensione e
della dimensione che stiamo vivendo 30
secondi possono anche essere molto
lunghi
al termine di quei 30 secondi in cui io
vedo lo sguardo del capo del villaggio
davvero provato da questa offesa
io prendo la parola senza che mi sia
stata data e senza averla chiesta e gli
dico guarda io rifiuto il te
perchè rifiuto l'idea
di bere nel tè i concimi del villaggio
che ti sta a monte
lui rimane un po perplesso
e io dopo altri 30 secondi continuo con
la mia con la mia spiegazione
il racconto vedi tu ogni giorno
distribuisci concimi nella tua terra
ogni giorno piove nei tuoi campi una
pioggia breve di durata ma intensa buona
parte la maggior parte la stragrande
maggioranza dei concimi che tu stai
distribuendo finiscono nel fiume
puoi essere fortunato e finiscono nella
falda quindi attraverso nel suolo ma
sempre nel fiume vanno a finire e allora
cosa stai facendo tu
con sacchi stanno portando a fare
attraverso questa somministrazione
gratis di concili che sembra un modo per
riscoprire una rivoluzione verde che da
altre parti del mondo
ha distrutto e sta distruggendo il
pianeta
perché
mi guarda sempre molto offeso e mi
chiede ma qual è l'alternativa
spiegare ad un capo di villaggio cos'è
una coltura di copertura
cioè che esistono delle specie che
possono essere utilizzate per coprire il
suolo creare un manto erboso sul suolo
delle specie in grado di
di arricchire al suolo di sostanza
organica richiede il suolo di elementi
minerali
naturalmente
naturalmente sembra una cosa difficile
sempre un processo difficile invece
fatto con parole semplici sempre
guardandosi negli occhi è stato molto
molto semplice
il capo del villaggio a quel punto mi
guarda e mi dice bene vorrei a questo
punto sapere se è disposto ad aiutarci a
realizzare tutto ciò
devo dire che questi sono quei momenti
inattesi in cui ci si rende conto che si
possono ottenere
successi significativi per la propria
vita e per il proprio modo di pensare di
essere di agire i momenti assolutamente
non prevedibili
non mi sarei mai aspettato quella
domanda dal capo del villaggio
chiaramente dopo la mia risposta
positiva ho cercato di spiegargli anche
l'importanza della biodiversità locale
di trovare specie della biodiversità
locale
ho cercato di spiegare il concetto di
vocazionalità ambientale il legame con
il suo territorio la necessità di
conservare l'ecosistema e lui sempre più
appassionato perché vedete io non ho
offeso il capo del villaggio perché sta
per che sta distruggendo l'ecosistema
per lui l'offesa più grande è stata
quella di pensare che non sta avendo a
cuore per come si dovrebbe la sua
comunità la salute della sua comunità e
allora lì
lì si rasserena l'attenzione si abbassa
la tensione e si comincia a discutere di
futuro si comincia a discutere di un
futuro che oggi è presente perché oggi
tutti i campi del pepe di rim basse del
presidio slow food sono gestiti senza
concimi con cultura di copertura
senza utilizzare più concili di sintesi
allora cosa mi ha insegnato questo mi ha
insegnato che è
che una transizione ecologica è
possibile
che ritornare alle pratiche di
agroecologia
dove l'agricoltura incontra l'ecologia
dove l'eco sistema sta sempre al centro
dove la conservazione delle risorse
naturali deve venire prima
dell'interesse dell'uomo
di questa visione antropocentrica che ci
sta portando verso la distruzione del
pianeta
ciò è possibile ed è possibile anche
come una goccia nel mare nel borneo
malese un puntino nel nella cartina del
mondo e se possibile li può diventare
contagioso può diventare estremamente
ripetuto in tantissime parti del mondo
e se noi agiamo in modo responsabile
noi possiamo aiutare le comunità a
sviluppare questi percorsi virtuosi
possiamo aiutare a raggiungere
l'obiettivo 12 produzione e consumo
responsabile che poi hanno delle
ricadute sugli obiettivo 14 e 15 mare e
terra le risorse di mare le risorse di
terra tutto ricompreso in quell'ambiente
in quel piccolo ecosistema della
comunità di rim bassa
ecco tutto questo però non avviene
entrando a gamba tesa
tutto questo avviene dalla condivisione
dal
dalla capacità di instaurare rapporti
vicendevole dalla volontà di ascoltarsi
l'uno con l'altro dalla volontà di
portare
informazioni utili per le comunità tutto
questo viene dalle relazioni e le
relazioni in quel giorno si sono
concluse col fatto che io ho bevuto la
tazza di tè
grazie
[Applauso]